[Music]
miss stutton
when a winner turkey dinner hi i'm kelly
riley and i play beth dunton on
yellowstone
you can't talk to me like that
yeah
you better have a big pistol in that
purse i do
it's called my name
beth dunn what's yours
people call me beth they'll come to me
and they'll be uh like wanting to
high-five me or or start a fight
it's really interesting how people
believe that you're your character i'm
going to stab you in the eye with this
block
this is the first time i've talked about
it properly
it's such a
personal process as well and
[Music]
people to hear me talk about her i think
is sort of
different as well because they have such
a
unique
idea of who she is
but this character is a beast i am the
rock therapists break themselves against
one thing i love about yellowstone and
beth in the casting is that taylor
sheridan has said
that he knew you were beth the minute he
saw you
in that tape well i didn't know i was
beth
um it took me a while to really find her
i mean it's like she's like stepping
into a sports car it was like how how do
i go from naught to 103 seconds and when
i first met him i hadn't found her yet
so um i don't i'm not sure what he saw i
do remember having a wobble moment where
i think where i thought i don't know if
i can i'm not sure i'm gonna be able to
pull this off um
because it is such a tremendously
complicated
role i wasn't sure if i was the right
person for it and then he just he would
fill my head he would call me up at
midnight and be like here here's what
you need to know about beth and he i
would i have notebooks and journals like
literally i would just be writing
everything down he would tell me i still
have them what do you want to make a
scene
you ready to watch that happen
beth's is
taylor's like creation and i and and all
i ever wanted to do was
um
was was
show him that i could do it and
make her real for him um because it is
such a bold brave character
i've made two decisions in my life based
on fear
and they cost me everything i remember
sitting down and doing rehearsals and i
and i'm certainly shyer than beth and
certainly took me a while to find my own
way into owning that confidence i
remember saying to him i'm going off a
cliff with her and i on anyway you bet
and i'm going to push you off that cliff
and i just remember thinking
all right i'm in for a ride here and
it's been
so much fun
yeah so that audition and just what he
saw in me i have no idea but i do
remember once i got it okay
i got it
yeah
not for me
when it comes to the accent in
particular how did you master that
well it's funny i mean i work with a
dialect coach who helps me and that's
just a bit of hard ground just sitting
at home just you know just going over
and over and over it i live in america
now so it it's i'm hearing it all the
time
but the first season when i first played
beth i didn't want anyone to
know that i wasn't american i mean
people knew but not everyone knew no the
crew didn't know and it's not that i
stayed in an accent but i just didn't
talk to anyone unless i was playing beth
that is destruction of personal property
assault is next you ready to see that i
didn't really want anyone to know that i
was so far removed from her
just personally um because if i came in
and was just myself
it sort of ruined the illusion and i
there was something about it for me it
wasn't about trying to convince
everybody else but for myself i just
needed to
to
really become her
i'm not going anywhere
just tell me how to fight
and it was only until like season three
did i start to hang out with everybody
you can ask them like
they probably thought i just didn't i
wasn't very friendly but i was just i
just didn't want anyone to
uh i didn't want the illusion
um to to break for myself so when the
cameras were off were you also still in
beth the beast mode too no i keep her
locked up in a box with a padlock
um
i'm not joking yeah it's four months of
the year where i get to play her is like
sort of going into battle
yeah i mean she's tough and then also
the language that um
that taylor how he writes her
um it's a mouthful it's like really hard
sentences um to sort of like just say so
easily and kill
what about the one-liners they're the
best the best yeah they're the best
i don't speak [ __ ]
you are the trailer park
i am the tornado
you bet on the wrong horse
these all get made into t-shirts i
actually got one for my mother-in-law
so she wears it sometimes but yeah no
it's um it's it's it's very strange how
she sort of pierced the psyche of
american women and i i'm not sure
because i think she's such a monster and
i love her
but she is um there's something about
her that's really empowered a lot of
women
um i think just being able to say those
things without any fear of retribution
sort of any you know there's no
no one can
come back at beth
better than than her
i'm the bigger bear
what is your favorite part about playing
beth
it's the most challenging role i've ever
played
ever and
i've played quite a few challenging ones
she's pretty thrilling and there's just
so many different aspects of her and so
i don't get to rest on my laurels and
just roll into work and
i have to work really hard and
prepare and
it's a challenge and i for me i love the
challenge of it
the sting never fades with me
she's a lot of fun to play like those
one-liners and stuff like there's two
parts of beth there's the one that you
know the the sting never fades beth that
one and then the one that is wanting to
try and protect her father and the ranch
and wants to find peace and is in love
with the man but she there's like these
two warring parts this season
vying for her attention and
it feels like it was
sort of on steroids this season
love you
after ruiner life
the need for revenge that she carries in
her i mean it's pretty
dark i mean it's very dark i feel like
beth this season was
on the wall path with everybody
you're gonna run everything aren't you
everything
when you're shooting those intense
scenes for example with beth and jamie
and the way she speaks to him
when the camera's cut
how do you get out of that what's that
like a lot of those scenes are really
difficult to play because they're so
filled with pain so they're they're
pretty brutal to to drop into
i want to see you be a man jamie huh
be a man
be a man
it's hard to talk about it honestly
because it's hard for me to i when i'm
when i'm playing her
i'm full in and then it's sort of like
coming out and then i watch it and i'm i
don't even remember doing some of the
things i'm gonna kill you jamie
yeah i feel really bad for jamie
sometimes i think the relationship with
jamie and beth
it's so toxic
it's so full of betrayal um and so full
of pain for her
i didn't ask you for a [ __ ]
hysterectomy
but i think the reason why all of that
exists is because she
loved him do you ever think there's
potential for that relationship to be
healed i don't know do you hope
what i hope is she will find some peace
and i think i don't think you can find
peace if you hold that much
pain if you haven't if you haven't sort
of dealt with some of those things
i'm something bad
you mentioned being full into her
obviously emotionally but physically now
too beth has a lot of trauma to her body
after everything she's been through she
was blown up at the end of season three
wait i don't know what that is don't
she has a scar on her back what is the
transformation process like for you when
we had to do the
burns on my back um
that would take
my calls were like three o'clock in the
morning to be on step for seven abby who
does the special effects makeup is
phenomenal at her job and she literally
laid on every single burn there were
literally like 45 pieces of individual
burns that she would paint on me so it
was a real artistry with it i love
when i'm beth all bashed up like that's
who she is there is that sort of that
warrior that's just in battle the whole
time and
and so the fact that she's getting scars
it just makes sense
[Music]
talk to us a little bit about working
with coal and
the relationship that you guys have that
you're able to make rip and bath what
that is if we didn't work together
there would no there wouldn't be any rip
and beth the relationship that is on the
page we're so lucky you don't know what
chemistry you're going to have with
another actor right you just have no
idea and you also don't know what the
audience are going to see so we didn't
know really until season two that that
was becoming a thing
i remember the first time i saw you
so wild
so angry
god you were beautiful and because
there's such hard asses both of them in
their own separate way and then they
come together and it's just
it's where they kind of lay down their
weapons and
this relationship it it
it's so powerful because there's so much
history to it and for so many years i
think beth resisted
that relationship because of what
happened to her
um so she kind of shut it down and shut
it out and then now you see her fully in
and this is just her guy you know and
it's beautiful
you're the craziest person i've ever met
in my life you know that
it's only the things i love that i rip
never make yeah
time to think of it i'm surprised you're
still standing
and i just love how he loves her one of
my favorite scenes of all time was when
he makes her breakfast in season three
you ever have fried bread
and how just simple an act of just
kindness
can just would just set her into a very
vulnerable place and i don't think beth
lets herself be vulnerable very often so
for me coal
provides a place
for me as the actor and beth is a
character
to soften
um
and
the passion that she has for him
i think is really beautiful
i love you
i see at the house
[ __ ] you all right baby
and cole and i work together as a team
like we're really good friends and we
really respect one another and we can
really ask each other we're like is this
working or is this not working and he'll
give me notes and i'll give him some
sometimes and we just help each other
out because we are aware of
of what what we've got in our hands
um and it's very rare
for something to be written so
beautifully and for the audience to
respond to it this way so there is a
responsibility to us which sometimes can
feel too heavy it's just such a
beautiful love story like it's almost
old-fashioned
the only thing i ask is that you
outlived me so i never have to live
another day without you
so now we have carter introduced into
this dynamic we're seeing a little bit
more of a maternal side of beth
hamburger helper
made with hamburger this time
how would you say
his addition into
their
dynamic has
kind of maybe changed things rip was
carter you know 30 years ago
so
um and beth recognized that straight
away you know there's a kid who
literally has nothing his life has just
fallen apart and
if she doesn't help him
you know she knows what his future is
and don't let anyone
outwork you
ever
at the same time these this is not
disney right so these are people who
haven't been raised particularly gently
themselves
it's not going to be necessarily a
kumbaya moment of like come to mama
and i i also think beth
is
guarded there's a there's a part of her
heart that probably doesn't think she's
capable of mothering
and also to open a heart to
to anyone is is quite a big deal so
that's going to be a slower burn than i
think everybody may have wanted i think
there was like oh suddenly there's a kid
in their life and they adopt it and it's
all and you get flavors of that you get
moments of those
those moments of real happiness genuine
happiness and i think family is
everything to beth and i just think it's
so nice to see beth happy because i
think that is where her happiness
lies when she's not trying to you know
destroy people actually this is what
makes her heart sting this is what makes
her you know really tick
which makes you happy don't it it does
it's nice to see her happy at the
kitchen table too because a lot goes
down at kitchen tables for beth oh my
goodness beth turns into a sort of 14
year old you know hormonal child at that
table i mean it's so full of ghosts for
her
um and i think taylor has such fun
writing those scenes
tantric what's that don't encourage her
it focuses on the erogenous zones
what erogenous zones
just pouring gas on the fire rip it's
almost like she walks into this portal
right when she goes into the dining room
it's like going back and it's
you know it's a reminder of everything
that she's lost at that table everything
that felt like real family to her her
mother who she it feels responsible for
for her death um her brother who's dead
and her father who is um
he's unable to just chill out in that
room and she hates it this is every meal
rip
this is where she gets a revenge
and this year it was so lovely that
scene where she's freaking out and doing
what she normally does and then
rip it's like what's the problem there's
another table right here what's the
problem
there's a table right here why don't we
eat right here
what do you say
and she hadn't thought of that so then
suddenly moving that dynamic simply
i think that table's gonna be set on
fire one day by her because she just
can't stand it
life is plenty hard you don't need to
help it hear me
obviously this character is very
personal to you yeah there i i i really
feel beth in my heart so it's like
i know what she
does for her father i mean she really is
a martyr for him she will she says i
will you know die defending his dream
protecting his land
his dream is my alamo
and
you know if you look at that really i
mean there's some dysfunction in that
that's taking loyalty and devotion and
love to i think something a little bit
um
damaged she
feels responsible for the death of her
mother
that terrible accident when she was a
child
and i mean her mother even told her that
this is this is your fault as she died
she did this
let her undo it
i think there is some unconscious part
of beth
really desperately trying to
compensate for that loss and she never
will
um forgiveness is such a big thing with
her
i don't think she can forgive herself
that
i work that [ __ ] out in therapy
and she's fighting so hard for him and
and and
everything she does is for him
no one's getting vengeance for what
happened there with the attack no one's
getting getting even with that she
doesn't understand it she wants to just
chop them all up you know and it feels
like he's letting it go
and
when she says
um
you know
keep the kingdom
or lose the kingdom like that's what it
is to her
and my loyalty
is the one thing on this planet that you
don't have to worry about
and it's so tricky too because when she
takes it too far especially with summer
she gets
fiercely protective
literally has a spat with summer in the
kitchen over it
who the [ __ ] are you who the [ __ ] are
you
i think summer isn't such an easy target
for beth um
um i mean she's so savage to her i i
it's awful
i spend a lot of time apologizing to the
actors i work with
i'm the [ __ ] about stubby in the
stomach i think there is
a territorial aspect to her
like i said there's a sort of juvenile
quality with her father it's almost like
she sort of stopped developing at the
age where the trauma happened
emotionally
and i think actually
you know she probably needs to go and do
some
work on that you know
this is my daughter
she can be a little overprotective with
the knife down honey it just you know it
doesn't take much for beth to flame up
and just you know go back
um
you know tenfold but summer doesn't know
who she's dealing with and of course
beth is just like feeding off it
hope you didn't pay full price for that
boob job actually
god gave me these for free looks like it
gave me yours too
what was that seem like between you
piper and kevin
was there any levity in that situation
the scene itself and it is kind of funny
beth is brutal to summer but we did have
fun i mean piper's a friend of mine and
you know it's just all in the writing
and we're just trying to just tell the
story as best we can and do those scenes
um just to have a bit of fun with them
but at the same time i mean we really
start to see this the dysfunction
in beth this season um if we didn't see
it before i think we see it this season
a lot
love you daddy
i hope you find a therapist who can help
you i hope you die of ass cancer
what is the dynamic like because i'm
just picturing you and kevin in that
situation what is the dynamic like
between you and kevin costner off camera
i see the little smile on your face i
know it's lovely i mean i'm working with
one of the great like iconic actors of
america and uh
playing his daughter he's i mean i'm
such i love watching him work i i love
his face
control for this [ __ ]
and i learn a lot from him as an actor
he's incredibly
um he's incredibly still and rooted and
you know i'm most the time being
kamikaze around him but
it's um
it's a real
pleasure and privilege to work alongside
him i think we all feel like that this
is the way
you know that don't you
yeah honey i just
just wish it wasn't
yeah i i mean i'm i'm from south london
i didn't think that i would be working
with such a legend in the middle of
montana and now being the number one
show
it's wild actually um i mean this is our
fourth season
so we've been doing this for a while and
we have such a hardcore fan base
and then for these numbers this year to
explode this way is just extraordinary i
mean mind-blowing those numbers are
unheard of so i don't usually pay
attention to the numbers you know but uh
i couldn't not this time
oh that cheered me up
what do you make of
all of the social media attention on
guys like cole and luke being
these
on-screen
sexy cowboys
i think they're as much surprised
um i think they're having fun with it
you know i think what emanates from cole
is this sort of
tough guy
real
masculine but um
but a softy so there's some there's a
quality in him that i think women just
go google and of course then he's got a
little toothpick and his little it's
like the cowboy fantasy yeah it's the
cowboys literally exactly
what was that about
just cowboy [ __ ] baby
i hope yeah stone goes for a long time
um and we get to see
the characters develop and um every
season for as long as we we can the
audience still wants it honestly as long
as our fans want it and people are still
enjoying it and we can still make a good
show then
i'd be i'd like to keep doing it but i
think it might be fun to see beth and
rip
when they're like
in their 60s
you know on the porch
you know i hope she's given up smoking
by then
um
i don't smoke so all of those cigarettes
are all they're all the herbal
cigarettes so i'm really hoping and i
hate them so much and he he has it in
the script how we know when she's
smoking and when she takes a drag it's
all written
and so i'm i'm really i'm trying to
pitch him an idea of that she gets
addicted to nicorette comes you know
so we'll see next year but if she's
smoking or not if she tries to choose
happiness
if she tries i wonder about that what
does that look like
but i i don't know if that's
entertaining
you know i don't know if that's what we
want to see from her
if a meteor strikes earth tonight
it is me and the cockroaches running
this [ __ ] tomorrow
[Music]
you